OK, so we're continuing our sort of tour through
the modern April twenty, twenty one Republican
Party, as it may be.
We already looked at an interview with a Republican
Trump supporter, a Republican donor who attended
this very strange event in Florida over the
weekend.
It was an individual who is experiencing completely
unhinged delusions and has fallen for baseless
conspiracy theories and is very, very secure
in those beliefs.
So that was that was a Trump supporter, Republican
donor.
Now, let's look at a little bit of what Donald
Trump said during his speech to these Republican
donors, because if they are to continue their
loyalty to him that we've seen so far and
and the things Trump said are the things that
continue being said heading into 2022 could
be an absolute bloodbath for the Republican
Party.
And in essence, Donald Trump's statements
to Republican donors over the weekend can
be summarized as lies.
Conspiracy theories and absolutely vitriolic
rants, including against his own fellow Republicans,
and that's what makes this absolutely fascinating.
For example, Donald Trump went on the attack
over the weekend against former Republican
Senate majority leader, now Senate Minority
Leader Mitch McConnell, with The New York
Times reporting that Donald Trump said the
following things and more, quote, Did he ever
say thank you to me talking about McConnell?
No, I hired his wife, referring to Elaine
Chao, Mitch McConnell's wife.
Did he ever say thank you to me?
No. Trump adding that, quote, A real leader
would not have accepted the results of the
twenty twenty election.
And Trump also reportedly, according to three
people in the room, referring to Mitch McConnell
as a, quote, dumb son of a bitch when Trump
attacked Mitch McConnell.
The reports are that the room of Republicans
really liked it and were loudly cheering.
Interesting.
But what does that mean for Republicans?
In twenty twenty two, Trump also went after
his own former vice president, Mike Pence,
Trump saying to the room full of donors, Pence
should have had, quote, the courage to refuse
to certify the results.
Understand that Trump's gripes with McConnell
and Pence were that they seemingly realized
Joe Biden won and did not humiliate themselves
above and beyond what they did do in order
to try to make that case.
Trump continued over the weekend to spread
election lies, even telling specific lies
about the results of the 2020 election in
particular states, and said that generally
the entire election was, quote, rigged.
Earlier in the show, we talked about how the
the Republican Party voters currently trust
Trump on medical issues more than they trust
Dr. Fauci and the CDC.
One of the things Trump did over the weekend
was go after Dr. Anthony Fauci.
The crowd reportedly loved that applause in
the room.
Now, why does this matter?
It matters because it's not typical that the
former Republican president, a former Republican
president, spends this much time attacking
his own party and certainly not as much as
he would spend attacking the other party.
And Trump did go after Joe Biden during the
speech.
It's all the normal stuff he's been saying
about Joe Biden.
It barely you can imagine what it is.
It's not particularly relevant or notable,
but Republicans always attack Democrats.
The question for the future of the Republican
Party is whether they will eventually come
around to deciding we are in this to defeat
Democrats or whether this split is going to
continue and lead to chaos and destruction
for the party in twenty, twenty two and potentially
also in 2024.
If they don't resolve this, it has the potential
to be, for me, delightfully disastrous for
several election cycles.
And this would be this would be a self-inflicted
destruction by the party brought on by the
fact that for a long time they have been fomenting
non-thinking, anti intellectual ism in the
party and understanding the history of this
matters.
This Trumpy and screed over the weekend from
Trump is now many, many, many layers removed
of what started during the Reagan era.
But it did start during the Reagan era.
And this would sort of be the just dessert
for it if you don't know the history.
A very brief outline is that in the Reagan
era, the move of the Republican Party was
towards a relatively ignorant but still cohesive
and winning strategy, which is let's come
out against welfare and lazy people who are
just living on the dole.
We want personal responsibility.
Let's be for low taxes.
Let's be for allowing business to flourish.
And it started to be used to provide cover
for racism and xenophobia.
That was the 80s under Reagan.
This appealed to some pseudo intellectuals
and ignorant people and people who maybe weren't
paying attention to politics previously.
And that got us to the early 1990s.
In the early 1990s, Newt Gingrich became speaker
of the House and he really ushered in, like,
if you imagine a staircase where at the top
is your party implodes into Trumpy and delusion.
The second step on that staircase is the early
90s.
Newt Gingrich becomes speaker of the House
and he plays up the reactionary rhetoric.
He takes another step away from policy and
towards nonsense.
But there's still a bunch of policy with Gingrich,
stuff about immigration, stuff about health
care.
There's still policy, but they're taking a
step towards the nonsense that we see today.
You then get George W. Bush, George W. Bush
by virtue of being kind of dim and completely
amoral and having that Texas cowboy per.
Penality appealed even more to the nonsense
over policy crowd, to the rhetoric over substance
crowd.
There was still policy.
It was pretty basic and rudimentary, lower
taxes.
That's good abortions.
Bad gay marriage is bad, you know, sending
troops around the world to defend us under
the guise of patriotism.
That's good.
Then you get Barack Obama's presidency and
that really shifts the scale even more.
You have a real influx and focus on a base
on the basis of xenophobia and racism and
the non-thinking side of the Republican Party.
And then the culmination is you have the perfect
electorate in the Republican primary to choose
someone like Trump.
And then we know, you know, the rest is history.
And so something that was birthed by the direction
the Republican Party chose in the 80s led
to Trump, even though it bears very little
resemblance to it.
Can it win them 20 20 to.
Can it win them 2024?
I have no idea.
It failed in twenty eighteen and it failed
in twenty twenty.
In those two elections, the Republican Party
lost the House, they lost the Senate and they
had a president lose the White House and become
a one term president.
Maybe it'll work in twenty, twenty two.
But this is really something they have to
figure out.
I hope they don't for the betterment
of
the country.